his ears are throwing me off I'm like  what's going on is that a disease  they're called cauliflower ears it's a  type of Chinese  learn martial arts and like go get away  from bullies and [ __ ] like you just have  that face that you got picked on a lot  what did they say it looked like he was  the stoner of the group he knows the  good drugs nailed it you're like the  quiet girl who doesn't like people but I  like to be around people do you think  that's true Julia that feels so opposite  but that's a relationship okay that's  for sure what's your take on him he's  like the cool nerd you know he's a nerd  but he's cool he can get into some nerdy  [ __ ] and we'll all be like oh we're lost  don't talk about cryptocurrency if I can  talk about some real [ __ ] that's spot on  do you watch the show yeah well I have  to watch the show  I've been study you guys for years